hey everyone welcome back and today we
have a real special guest dr. nadir Ali
is here and he is a keto friendly
cardiologist from Houston Texas so
welcome welcome to this channel can you
hear me I I can hear you well okay great
thank you
I am honored to be here on this channel
and I'm honored to be a part of your
program and as I told you I have had a
long-held admiration for you many of my
patients are avid fans of yours and your
Friday podcast so they look forward to
it they come and give me all kinds of
feedback I have learned how to
communicate with my patients based on
what you do to some degree Wow Wow thank
you that's awesome well I'm really a
pleasure to meet you meet you in person
or actually sort of through the line
internet lines here you know just for
everyone's knowledge you're gonna be one
of the main speakers at our next Quito
summit coming up in August at the end of
August August 31st and September 1st
it's uh I think it's Labor Day weekend
and we're gonna have a blast so I'm
really excited to have you come out and
speak you know you you bring to the
table something very unique I mean you
know one of the big things right now hot
topics is this cholesterol thing and the
LDL and people are concerned and you see
these things in the in the news where oh
don't to key though it's gonna raise
your cholesterol and you're gonna die
have a heart attack
yeah I yeah and so I'm coming just from
your field I mean I guess that's what
what you're taught right in school like
I guess the whole cholesterol dogma has
been pushed so much it's so ingrained in
us that it's sometimes it's hard to look
at the actual data what's your what's
your thought on that
that's like delving right into it and
I'm glad you're doing it that way
because we don't waste time in
unnecessary stuff exactly but I've been
practicing for almost 30 years and as a
cardiologist and the dogma that has been
taught to us is that low cholesterol low
LDL is one of the best things for you to
do and unfortunately if you compile all
information about optimal human
nutrition about human brain size about
what we need to eat and how we need to
behave to reduce our LDL cholesterol C
Nevitt ibly it's going to lead to very
poor health it's gonna lead to obesity
insulin resistance diabetes hypertension
all the chronic diseases that are going
to reduce your quality of life that's
gonna make you die earlier and so I was
kind of surprised that there's such a
huge paradox between LDL cholesterol and
every other biomarker of health you can
take anyone you know they go in opposite
direction if you want to improve your
insulin resistance your LDL is going to
go up if you want to reduce your weight
your LDL is going to go up interesting
interesting so I started thinking about
this as a paradox but then when you put
everything together you understand that
that's how our body is probably designed
to behave and so I go out there now for
the last five years it took me time to
understand why LDL goes up on a low-carb
diet
and it took me time to understand that
that is not necessarily bad and in some
ways having higher LDL cholesterol with
very good other biomarkers might be
something to celebrate not my own and I
could elaborate on some of that but I
wanted more interaction I wondered you
to kind of chime in and say hey I want
to lead this podcast in this direction
yeah exactly because I wanted to there's
some there's some things that I'm
interested in personally that I would
like to know your viewpoint on you know
cholesterol LDL this is called bad
cholesterol but really it's a it's a
cargo ship
it's a transport ship and it delivers
cholesterol we need cholesterol I'm
hoping that most people know that our
body makes cholesterol but what I'm
interested to just start off with
talking about is your take on LDL
actually carries I think all of the fat
soluble vitamins but I'm an a de K k1
and k2 have you seen any data on that
especially even vitamin e to as an
antioxidant I think it does the data on
this is kind of not at least I'm not
aware of some very good data on that
okay that vitamin D does have its own
carrier protein and that may be the LDL
is a secondary mechanism for carrying
vitamin D around but I guess one of the
other major functions of LDL would be to
carry Co Q 10 because I'm not sure all
the muscle cells are capable of making
the Co Q 10 that they need for
mitochondrial function and but you're
right LDL is a carrier molecule not just
for triglycerides and cholesterol per se
but for many antioxidants fat soluble
vitamins
Co Q 10 yeah and I do know that you have
all these phospholipids as well that our
I think it's a that make up the cell
wall and so we have a transport system
of cholesterol cholesterol doesn't just
float around by itself it needs to be
transported and I think that if you
could just touch a little bit on the the
necessary function of LDL that's one
area I wanted to want to touch on and
then also I want you to maybe mention a
little bit about statins and what the
problem with statins that you run into
I'm sure that you know it's a hot topic
with in your field I mean I'm a lot of
cardiologists prescribe them right so
let's first talk about cholesterol in
general and then move on to allyl
cholesterol in particular cholesterol in
general is an extremely important
molecule for life there is no life on
earth without cholesterol every living
cell has cholesterol if you go back to
some of the earliest parts of evolution
when we started out as single-celled
beings in this world those single cells
also had cholesterol really if you look
at cholesterol it is an integral part of
every cell membrane the cell membrane
gets its structural integrity the
fluidity so that it acts as a barrier
because cholesterol is connecting the
phospholipids in such a way that it is
providing those functions
the second major way to think about
cholesterol is to look at brain function
because in our brain there are these
cholesterol rafts and these rafts are
locations where neurotransmitters set so
the structural integrity of the
neurotransmitter receptors
is because of these cholesterol rafts
and if you deprive the brain of
cholesterol the integrity of these
neurotransmitter receptors is affected
so there is a lot of data that comes out
and says that there are certain statins
that cross the blood-brain barrier can
have significant cognitive dysfunction -
and in fact cholesterol is so important
for the brain that it does not delegate
the responsibility to any other organ to
make cholesterol it makes its own Wow
and I often joke that I would not be
able to deal with the stress of being a
cardiologist or giving this podcast if
it were not for cholesterol because the
LDL molecule is supplying cholesterol as
raw material to my adrenal gland so that
it can make the stress hormone which is
called cortisone and and that's an
absolutely amazing fact that many of the
hormones the backbone of that is a
cholesterol molecule and the carrier
molecule that is supplying that
cholesterol to make that is the LDL and
I often joke to audiences saying that
hey men look handsome because of LDL
cholesterol I like that and the reason
is is because the LDL is the one that is
supplying testes with cholesterol the
raw material to make testosterone and
similarly women look beautiful because
their ovaries also need cholesterol to
convert cholesterol to estrogens so
these are functions that are sometimes
completely skimmed over when we tried to
knock the LDL down like crazy and say
hey we the lowest is better and it made
no sense to me as a cardiologist because
I've been practicing for 30 years and I
have seen people come in having
extensive three vessels heart disease
with blockages everywhere with
cholesterol levels as low as 50 Wow Wow
and I have seen 90 year old women or
older with LDL cholesterol in the mid to
hundreds who I take them to the cardiac
cath lab and I find that they have the
most beautiful blood vessels that you
and I although maybe several decades
younger would be happy to trade those
blood vessels for them
Wow Wow that's that's fascinating so
I've been a bit of a skeptic all my life
about this cholesterol being a causal
factor in coronary artery disease
because it made no sense and if you
really take the trouble to talk to
patients you would find that they
complain of all kinds of side effects on
cholesterol reducing medicines it's just
that the medical profession has moved in
such a direction that we rely so much on
information coming in from societies
that we have given up our clinical
acumen we have given up our critical
thinking ability we want to just follow
guidelines we don't want to do our own
work we don't listen to patients we
don't want to be skeptics as a physician
I think it's highly necessary for us to
be quite skeptical about every
information and use our clinical
intuition when we are taking care of
patients exactly I also was fascinated
that the LDL cholesterol is so involved
in host defense and this is not
something many people talk about because
host defense that means how we protect
against bacteria and viruses is in some
ways mediated by the LDL cholesterol
put out some elegant information from
different studies that I have looked at
in which like for example there is this
fascinating paper which looked at a
mouse lung and they infected the mouse
lung with bacteria and these bacteria
they elaborate a little protein that
goes in as a pilot to investigate and
see if the milieu is suitable to
establish an infection so the bacteria
themselves is smart they won't go in and
start an infection without checking the
area out first and that marker protein
comes back and gives an information to
the bacteria it's called quorum sensing
protein and it comes back and says hey
let's establish infection and I was
surprised to find that in this paper
this elegant work that shows that it is
the LDL cholesterol that is going in
there and neutralizing this protein so
that bacterial infection cannot gain a
foothold Wow fascinating fascinating I
definitely want to get a copy of that so
um it yes it actually has ability to
attack pathogens it also has the ability
to bring antioxidants into a certain
area and dump vitamin E into an
epithelial wall to help protect against
lesions I mean now most the time from my
viewpoint it seems like people go on a
keto program and it lowers the LDL but
then you have people that have a higher
LDL lets us talk about what would be
some of the reasons why someone would
actually cut the carbs down and their
LDL would go up any reason for that yeah
that's one of my strengths I think that
I'd like to take a little credit that
I'm the first one to point out in a
national audience now as to the
molecular mechanisms why LDL is going up
and and I'm so glad that
you brought that up because this is
something that has bothered me a lot you
know as a cardiologist for the last five
years I have been practicing a low carb
diet myself and recommending it to a lot
of patients and I have been seeing that
as many you know in large majority of
these patients as they lose weight as
their diabetes improves as they come off
diabetic medications as their
triglyceride levels go down as their HDL
level goes up the one troubling finding
that was happening is that the LDL goes
up and it goes up unlike what people
think it goes up almost in everyone it
may go up to a variable degree but it
goes up in everyone so I wanted to
explain why that is happening and in the
final analysis I think this is and
although this is my model and it's not
being proven in studies yet but I think
that's what we should do is that when
you are going on a low-carb diet by
design you're burning fat we have very
limited carbohydrate reserves we run out
of them in a situation in which we stop
eating like intermittent fasting or
going on a fast for several days you're
gonna run out of carbohydrate reserves
in about six to eight hours and then
your body predominantly becomes fat
burning so it's burning triglycerides
and it's there are certain tissues that
cannot directly burn triglycerides so
what it does is that the liver takes the
triglycerides and converts them to
ketones
so the liver is the only organ that has
the enzymatic machinery to make ketones
so it's taking the triglycerides it
converts the triglycerides to acetyl co
a which then enters the mitochondria and
then the acetyl co it through a series
of enzymatic reaction gets converted to
HMG
Kawai now hmg-coa fascinatingly is a
branch point it's the same raw material
that cholesterol uses to make
cholesterol in the body that means
hmg-coa can go on and make cholesterol
and hmg-coa can also get converted to
ketones that's right
interesting so if by design you are
doing better oxidation of fat it just
means that you're burning fat if you're
burning fat you are making a lot of
ketones and if you're making a lot of
ketones by design you're going to make a
lot of cholesterol in the liver and I'm
not just basing this on hypotheses there
are a lot of animal studies that are
human studies that give you indirect
evidence that this is what is happening
and if you think it's right I want to
take you through a few of these yeah
yeah I think you know it's it's it makes
total sense because ya could go split
off this way and make ketones or
cholesterol so I do remember that
chemistry so like wow I never actually
considered that viewpoint but that that
makes a lot of sense and I think the
this in this day and age the reason it's
important to collaborate is because a
biochemist is not gonna completely look
at that point and say hey I want to
think about it that way right neither is
a nutritionist and not as a cardiologist
along because they don't understand the
details of the biochemical steps in the
liver but when you put all of these
people together in a podcast like yours
or at a local conference it starts
gelling this information and that's how
we would make advanced by collaborating
right so I to go back into this
information so there is there are these
drugs which are being used for diabetes
which are called sglt2 inhibitors in
Kanna is one of them Giardia --nz is one
of them and basically what these drugs
do is that our body filters sugar in the
kidneys but it reabsorbs most of the
sugar but these drugs poison the kidney
tubules in such a way that you don't
reabsorb the sugar that you're filtering
so basically you're dumping sugar so
when you're dumping sugar and if you're
not eating carbs or if you are let's say
fasting the body switches to fat
metabolism because you don't have sugar
available you're going to do now fat
burning so when they started using this
in humans they started noticing that
ketone levels go up they also started
noticing that LDL cholesterol levels go
up and fascinatingly in some of these
studies now that since there is no
conflict here in the sense that the
pharmaceutical companies and I'm sorry
for being a skeptic but the
pharmaceutical companies want to show
that hey dumping sugar and reducing your
blood sugar is beneficial for you and by
the way it'll be helpful for you to
prevent heart disease and that's what
they found but they could not explain
hey you're improving heart disease but
your LDL levels are going up and so
there's an accompanying paper that's
done in a in a hamster which goes into
the biochemical mechanisms with this so
what's happening is that as you are
dumping sugar you are not making more
ketones and as you're making more
ketones the liver is synthesizing more
cholesterol and since the liver has a
higher amount of cholesterol
it doesn't need cholesterol for itself
otherwise what the liver does is that
hey cholesterol is so important for me
let me soak up some cholesterol from
circulation and it has these LDL
receptors
these receptors are there that soak up
the cholesterol from the circulation and
remove it for liver to be able to use it
but since LDL since liver is
synthesizing so much cholesterol it
doesn't need that cholesterol from
circulation so it down regulates the LDL
receptors and also since it's making so
much cholesterol and since cholesterol
is not a metabolic fuel in other words
we can't burn cholesterol like we can
burn sugar and triglycerides the only
way for us to eliminate it is in bile
well the paper shows that your
cholesterol elimination and bile goes up
so you can see that the feces are now
filled with cholesterol Wow Wow and
another fascinating mechanism that they
talked about is that the LDL cholesterol
is in some way an antioxidant it it is
fighting antioxidant injury and it gets
oxidized in the process when it gets
oxidized in the process it gets picked
up by the macrophages through a certain
receptor so the macrophages go around
and say hey this LDL has done its job
let me just pick it out from circulation
and this paper shows that these
macrophages that are laden with oxidized
LDL cholesterol their elimination
through the gut through feces is
promoted in the setting of fat oxidation
so here is a complete picture you're
burning fat you're making more ketones
you're making more cholesterol in the
liver and hence you gonna make more LDL
because the liver has to mobilize that
cholesterol it's going to down regulate
the LDL receptors because it doesn't
need cholesterol anymore it's gonna up
regulate cholesterol elimination so your
bile acid production goes up the
elimination of body goes
and it also improves the elimination of
oxidized cholesterol fascinating so so
um a couple things if you're getting an
increase by all production you could
also have could be create a laxative
effect you could have a little diarrhea
maybe some of the side effects but the
question I have is that time so people
are probably understanding this now but
they're thinking is this extra
cholesterol going to stick and my
arteries and clogged up an artery that's
I think that's the big question that
they are concerned about so I think that
one thing I would like to humbly submit
is that we don't understand the
molecular mechanisms why we get plaque
in our blood vessels and I almost
hesitate to call it an adverse periodic
plaque because that gives it a
connotation that somehow cholesterol is
the culprit so I want to stay and say
hey it is plaque formation and to say
that the LDL is the primary culprit that
gets on to the vascular wall onto the
sub endothelium and I know I want to be
cognizant on by not using too many
medical terms that is the layer just
beneath the lining of a blood vessel and
then initiate a response in which you
are making plaque is by no means
scientifically agreed that that are the
mechanisms
it is quite equally possible that the
LDL cholesterol is there to help repair
an injury that happened as a result of
oxidative stress which means that
whenever you burn something you create
an injury an oxygen when it is used in a
certain way creates an injury at the
level of the vessel and that could be
from high blood pressure
that would be from result of an
infection that could be because you have
insulin resistant and as a result of
that you have systemic inflammation that
is leading to vascular injury and is
this vascular injury being promoted by
the LDL or is the LDL just there to help
prevent oxidative damage and in the
process you see it around and that does
not mean that it is the culprit and one
of the many people from whom I have
borrowed this line is that if you order
a scene of a fire you're gonna see
firefighters but you're never gonna
blame the firefighters for causing the
fire right right and so is the case with
the LDL I'm not sure it is there too
cause I don't know if it's the culprit I
don't know if it is there to help right
the paradox is that you see vascular
damage in people with very low LDLs and
you see no vascular damage in people
with LDLs in the mid to hundreds and it
simply does not jive that it is a graded
culprit if it is a graded culprit you
should see consistency of effect right
and if it's a graded culprit you should
see that hey if I reduce my cholesterol
LDL cholesterol down to 30 milligrams
per deciliter since this is my primary
hypothesis that this is what is causing
vascular injury I should see no vascular
injury and I can take you through many
papers in which they have dropped the
LDL down to 30 milligrams and have
changed the event rate either by less
than half a percent or have done it in
the opposite direction so to me that
makes no sense and this is the kind of
critical thinking that I want
physicians who are taking care of
patients to do is that you cannot rely
on relative risk reduction that many of
the papers talk about but you want to
look at absolute risk reduction you want
to look at the integrity of data you
need to be a skeptic and see who is
doing the studies and what is their bias
behind that right right yeah they just I
think they in 2005 they came out with a
rule I'm not sure how well drug
companies follow it that they have to be
more transparent upload all the research
on a given drug I don't know if they're
following that but before 2005 they you
could selectively publish what you
wanted to publish unfortunately so if
you're if you as a doctor researching
and you're only getting half the picture
you're just you're gonna see something
that's not not the true data one thing I
was gonna ask you
being a cardiologist what when you're
looking into an artery looking at plaque
do you find a certain pattern of where
that plaque is located is it always in
the carotid arteries is it in another
artery does it happen in certain high
pressure areas or does it just random
well to a large degree it does happen
with there are where there is shear
stress so you know shear it could be a
medical term so basically at a branch
point the blood flow is not laminar the
you know laminar is smooth blood flow
turbulence is when the blood flow is not
smooth and our areas of branch point
there is possibility of turbulence and
at this point there is a lot of stress
on the vessel wall and that can happen
as a result of high blood pressure that
can happen as a result of the blood
vessels getting constricted which means
getting smaller so you predominantly see
flag buildup
those locations but it can also be found
at other places that are more or less
random that you would say hey this is a
process that you can predict to some
degree that it will happen at branch
points and are places of high shear
stress but it can also happen in other
locations so like for example you
mentioned the carotid arteries the
carotid arteries bifurcate when I say
bifurcate they divide into two blood
vessels right here in the neck and at
this point one blood vessels going and
supplying the brain the other blood
vessel is supplying the face and at that
branch point there is more likelihood of
you getting buildup of plaque and
buildup of blockages and I'm trying to
stay away from saying buildup of an
asterisk erotic plaque right because
that implies a certain causation and
then you what about the coronary
arteries that is that more common than
the carotid so both occur concurrently
like if you have coronary artery disease
the likelihood that you can have carotid
artery disease is about 50% and if you
have carotid artery disease the
likelihood of you having coronary artery
disease goes up dramatically and what
goes up even higher a more a further
end-stage that means a more advanced
stage of vascular disease would be
blockages in the blood vessels of the
leg so if you have lock edges in the
blood vessels on the leg the possibility
that you have heart disease which means
blockages carotid disease the blood
supply to the brain and kidney disease
is very high so unfortunately people
with blockages in their blood vessels
that demonstrates that there is a more
advanced vascular disease present in
them and hence you would find it in
other locations as well interesting
the patients that come see you are they
coming with blood pressure or are they
coming because they already been
diagnosed and they need surgery what
type of clients come to see you so in
the first 24 years of my practice I
predominantly tried to work in the
cardiac cath lab so I would see patients
referred to me with blockages in the
blood vessels of the heart and I would
take them to the cath lab and put stents
in them and fix them and these people do
have high blood pressure
many of them are diabetic many of them
have I would say I hate to use the term
high cholesterol I would say poor
quality cholesterol I've started using
that term and poor quality cholesterol
and my view is somebody who's got high
triglycerides and low HDL and if you
divide or if you evaluate their LDL
cholesterol properly it is the small
dense molecule and launch not the large
and fluffy molecule so they had a number
of these factors and I would open them
up in the in the cardiac cath lab but in
the last five years have gone through a
transformation and I said hey if this
nutrition works and me I should try it
in my patients and so now I spend more
and more time at least 50% of my time or
more in the office and I am surprised
that I on a weekly basis get calls from
people in New York California Arizona
New Mexico and Louisiana saying that hey
we want to come see you Wow for for
nutritional advice for questions that
they have about the LDL and you know and
I tell them that look it's I feel
uncomfortable that you need to travel
all the way to come see me
I'm sure that you will find a local
practitioner nearby who can give you all
the information that you need because
it's too much for somebody to travel
take an airplane just to come see a fish
in our short office is it so now I'm
beginning to see more and more people
who are coming purely for nutritional
advice and I say okay yeah I will do
that but you will be surprised that when
you're giving nutritional advice you
uncover that their poor nutrition has
contributed to insulin resistance high
blood pressure diabetes obesity in so
many different ways and I am surprised
that the impact of nutrition and
lifestyle is so much greater than
medications Wow it's it's it's an order
of magnitude greater than medications
without the side effects and I'm not
sure why people are not working at that
and and and and that's why my opening
slide at low carb Denver said I'm
concerned that the medical profession is
gonna get buggy whipped that's funny
because they are not listening to the
grass root movements that says hey I'm
doing all these things and I am
improving why as a medical professional
are you not looking into this right
right
I know it's it's starting it's like oh
it's like a wild flower flower just
spreading all over the place so yes it
may be if you if you don't
after all it comes down to the patient
and the patient does want this shift is
they want alternatives they don't
necessarily like the drugs they want to
get off the drugs so they're looking for
doctors like you and that can actually
give them a good good information so
yeah things are really really changing
that's so you you basically you you must
have a lot of actually probably very
enjoyable to take someone where you can
see it's pretty obvious and then
completely shift them but by changing
their diet it's just it's such a big of
that you can create that probably before
yeah I know in my practicing before I
knew about some of this stuff you know
I'd be treating these specific symptoms
with all these different pills people
would go home with a hundred pills and
all these vitamins and stuff but I
didn't work on the basics I didn't get
the eating corrected until I started
doing that like the need for all these
other things go way down so it's just
remarkable so I'm so happy that I had a
chance to talk to you I and get this
great data and I'm excited to have you
come out so those of you that are
watching you should come out and
definitely come to our event it's going
to be at the end I'll put a link down
below and I also want to put a link to
your YouTube channel so people can start
watching your videos I think you're
starting to release more videos yes
that's true they come either under my
name which is Nadira lee md and they
also come under eat mostly fats
nutrition all right some of them are
being released by keto fast and look up
down under but if I mean I want to
entice your audience and not that your
your conference is not going to be
completely sold out I heard that last
year you did it on very short notice and
even though you did it on short notice
there were no seats that were unfilled
and people were waiting in line but I
wanted to still entice them to come
because the talk that I am working on
right now and which is very fascinating
is to answer the question as to what is
optimal human nutrition and the way I
want to approach that area is by looking
at these concepts and I'll just leave
you with the concepts I'll not define
them in any particular way one of them
would be what is called the extensive
tissue hypothesis what that simply means
is that we have such an enormous energy
expensive brain that is three times the
size that you would
predict based on our body size or any
primate ancestor there's 2% of our body
mass and it consumes 20% energy so
feeding that brain is very important the
second aspect of that would be that how
our digestive system has modulated and
evolved over these periods what is the
diet that is suitable for us
the third thing would be what is our
pancreas doing our pancreas kind of
evolved without the stresses that the
modern diet is putting on it and it's
not capable of handling glycemic load
that we are giving to it in this day and
age with the diet that PE and then
finally I want to look at the microbiome
you know we have a gut that has bacteria
in it and how important is the
microbiome how important is is
fermentation and there are many other
concepts that are going to come in play
to evaluate the most optimal human
nutrition Wow you guys you have to come
to learn about this this is gonna be
exciting I can't wait to hear you it's
gonna be good thank you I hope I
delivered on my promise I think you will
you're you're a great presenter and
you've filled with gold it's great great
and rate data so thank you so much and
I'm looking forward to talking more with
you in a couple of months I absolutely
enjoyed being on your podcast Eric and
I'm honored that I'll be a part of your
conference awesome thank you